NARRATOR: Nearly 6,000
feet up in the mountains,
another mom has
a huge challenge.
A female black bear
has spent the winter
in a high mountain cave.
She needs to teach her cubs
to survive in the park.
With little to no food
or water for months,
the stakes are high.
But they're living
in a special place.
Big Bend is the
only national park
with an entire mountain range
inside its borders, the Chisos.
Named for their
previous inhabitants
and once home to the Mescalero
Apache and the Comanche tribes,
the mountains are
a sky island oasis.
40 square miles of
peaks up to 8,000 feet
loom over the hot desert below.
At the height of
summer, monsoon storms
can dump nearly a year's
rainfall in a few months.
Right now, the monsoon
is a long way off,
but the Chisos do
something incredible.
They catch the rains and
store them for year round use.
Water slowly releases
from deep in the mountains
into precious spring-fed
pools, attracting critters
of all types and all colors.
The key to survival in a desert
is a reliable source of water.
And Mom knows exactly where
to find it thanks to her mom
who taught her about the
hidden oases in the Chisos.
It's the cubs' first visit
to this magical place.
Every day is a school day.
Today's lesson is
all about water.
They've never tasted
or seen so much of it.
Mom relaxes in the spring, but
for the cubs, it's play time.
The fun has to come
to an end eventually,
but Mom has another lesson
for her eager students,
how to scratch that itch.
Mom shows how it's done,
rubbing off her winter coat
and leaving a scent behind,
signaling her presence
to other bears in the park.
Mom made it look
easy, but the cubs
will need a lot more practice.
For the bear family, the
Chisos mountains provide
water and a cool refuge.
But down below on the desert
floor, life in the park
has more extreme challenges.